Film Courage: What’s the process of what
you do that we don’t see?
Dale Stelly, Filmmaker: Good question.
With me being a producer, before I can direct
I need to go out there because my film either
lock in an investor or lock in a budget.
A lot of times as me the filmmaker I’m spending
80 percent of the time finding an executive
producer or locking in funds and 20 percent
of the time creating a film.
I want to switch it around.
I want to spend 80 percent of the time shooting
a movie and only 20 percent of the time locking
in the investors.
So what people don’t see is before I get
to the set they don’t know what I had to
go through to lock in a producer, lock in
a budget, be able to hire everybody, be able
to feed everybody, be able to have a situation
to shoot this movie.
No one sees the business behind-the-scenes
side of it.
They just see “Oh?
We’re shooting on the red cameras?
Oh?
We’re working with Vida Guerra or Malik
Whitfield today.”
You know what I mean?
They just see physical glitz and glamor part.
They don’t really see like me in my home
office on the phone in email conjuring up
potential deals or potential relationships
that leads to producing movies or what have
you so people don’t see that part.
People just think like “Oh?
The camera just shows up.”
And the craft service just pays for itself…well
I don’t think they think that but people
just don’t see what it takes to get a production
like financing and going and meeting deadlines.
It looks easy and it looks like we’re having
fun on set when we are working with certain
talent and certain equipment and stuff but
it’s not easy it just looks easy.
Film Courage: Going back to that one set in
1995 when you were doing craft service, did
you think it was easy from watching your friend
[referring to a story Dale us in a prior interview]?
Dale: You know what, it did look easy.
I remember being 19 or 20…yes I was 20 in
’95 and I remember my boy Daniel Zirilli
sitting in the chair (the director chair)
and all this dude was saying was “Action!
Action!
Action!”
I’m like “Yo?
Wait a minute?”
That’s all he is doing is this directing
the talent and the talent and the talent is
doing everything.
He made me figure out how to get in that chair
and it was not easy at all.
It looks easy once you are on the set and
you’re like “Hey roll camera, roll sound.
We’ve got speed…okay action!”
All that stuff looks fun and easy but no one
knows that you first of all had to have a
body of work to even have booked the job that
was going on.
You need to have a reel, you need to have
a website, you needed to say the right thing
and answer the questions professionally and
speak articulately.
Everything matters before you get to set and
some people don’t realize that it takes
a lot of hard work to get in that director’s
chair to be to be working with big names or
big companies.
It takes a lot of success to get to that point.